what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
today we have some big announcements
about the X-Men the Marvel Cinematic
Universe specifically for Avengers
Secret Wars and Deadpool 3. there are
some X-Men coming to these movies that
fans are going to be extremely excited
to hear about and of course see on the
big screen not to mention we do have
some San Diego Comic-Con announcements
coming with just a little over a month
left until San Diego Comic-Con we know
Marvel Studios is preparing for
something big so we'll break down what
to expect in this video and if you love
Marvel be sure to subscribe to the
channel we talk about it every day we
also have a website a patreon account
and a Discord server if you want to join
and we're doing a huge giveaway giving
away an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items we pick a
winner at the end of each month there
are only two days left and the winner
gets to pick one item all you have to do
to enter subscribe and leave a comment
down below so as far as the X-Men are
concerned and Sandy Diego Comic-Con is
concerned we're really hoping to hear
something about mutants from Kevin feige
and Marvel's Hall age panel this year at
sdcc it's been a pretty long time since
the last time Kevin feige has truly
teased us about the X-Men and the MCU or
the mutants as he calls them and if you
are wondering he has said that those two
terms are interchangeable to him they
mean the same thing to him so if you
hear Kevin feige say mutant instead of
X-Men it doesn't exactly mean anything
and he did also confirm that whatever
they are going to do with the X-Men and
the mutants is going to be quite
different than anything that we've seen
before on screen I know you know you you
did mention other movies in addition to
the 11 that you titled up on screen and
you name dropped Fantastic Four but you
only referred to the X-Men as Pope
mutants and I'm curious are you guys not
looking to go the route of a traditional
X-Men titled uh movie for those
characters I was mutant's an X-Men are
interchangeable I just said I just said
mutants
um but yes whatever we do will be quite
different and it's hard to believe that
the last time that he's really mentioned
this was in 2019 now granted the
pandemic happened in San Diego Comic-Con
didn't happen for a bit but now we're
back at it and hopefully we can get some
type of an update from the mutants from
Kevin feige at San Diego Comic-Con but
as far as what his actual plan is
currently for the X-Men and the MCU we
seem to apparently know that and that
plan seems to get clearer and clearer as
we get closer and closer to Avenger
Secret Wars and Deadpool 3. and Deadpool
3 is going to be a key movie in bringing
some X-Men to the MCU because as we have
found out Kevin feige's plan for the
X-Men is to actually bring the older
X-Men back first from the fox franchise
and then introduce new X-Men this is
apparently going to be Kevin feige
send-off for the X-Men he started his
career with Marvel working on the X-Men
films the original one with Hugh Jackman
bamka Patrick Stewart you know the
Classic X-Men movies that we all love
and the ACT actors have expressed for a
while since the MCU has been formed that
they wish they had that opportunity to
be a part of something like the MCU or
the actual MCU and based off of what
we've heard Kevin feige's plan is to
kind of make that dream come true and
bring them into Avengers Secret Wars now
we've heard of some actors coming back
already of course like Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine Patrick Stewart has already
returned in Multiverse of Madness and
has already hinted that him and Ian
McKellen are not done with Marvel yet so
we know they're going to return
basically but today we have a report on
a few more original X-Men returning for
Secret Wars in Deadpool 3. according to
The Insider can we get some toast for a
birthday scoop and happy birthday to you
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine won't be the
only X-Men returning in Deadpool 3.
Holly Berry bombka Jensen and James
Marsden will also reprise their roles as
storm Jean Gray Phoenix and of course
Cyclops now recently Holly Berry
actually kind of teased that she would
be returning a storm she recently posted
a picture of herself on Instagram with a
caption patience takes practice and as
you can see in the photo she has white
hair what's interesting about this is
this kind of fits at two different
things here one she's holding a cat and
patience was the name of her character
in Catwoman so some people have went oh
my gosh we're getting a Catwoman sequel
I don't think that's the case I don't
think anybody asked for that but you
never know but the other thing of course
that people are noticing is that she has
white hair and Deadpool 3 right now is
starting everything all the filming is
about to go down with Deadpool 3 and the
X-Men are said to play a pretty
significant role in that movie in fact
based off of the rumors and the leaks so
far what we know about Deadpool 3 is
that Deadpool is kind of going to be
hired by the TVA kind of like Loki was
kind of hired by the TVA do you deal
with a certain problem Loki had to deal
with variants of himself but Deadpool
instead of getting pruned has a chance
to help the TVA and help himself by
going to a universe where the X-Men
actually have dominated it and Rule it
it's under Magneto's Reign and all of
the other X-Men follow him as well
including Professor X from what we've
heard and if the reports that we've
heard are true then Deadpool and
Wolverine are going to have to go into
this universe and essentially kill
everybody so it is essentially the story
of Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
but the story of the X-Men doesn't stop
there because Kevin feige's big send-off
is supposedly Secret Wars so what this
is going to do is simply prepare the
audience that the X-Men these old X-Men
characters can return as variants of
themselves in movies in the MCU now this
is what they showed us in Multiverse of
Madness as well these old characters can
return and will return now Deadpool is
going to probably visit a bunch of
different universes it's a Multiverse
Journey with Wolverine the Fantastic
Four the original ones are supposed to
show up and of course these original
X-Men are supposed to show up as well
Deadpool's gonna go to a lot of
different universes and probably start
to mess things up and probably cause
some incursions leaving problems for our
main Avengers team and the other teams
in the MCU but the variants that we see
in Deadpool 3 are probably going to be
different than the variants that we see
in Avengers Secret Wars but to top it
off The Insider can we get some toast
followed up and said there are two other
cast members returning for Deadpool 3.
one from the fox X-Men movies and one
from the MCU they're villains and you'll
never guess who I'll reveal them in due
time because it's far too early so for
now have fun speculating and if you have
any big speculations about this please
let us know in the comments down below
what you're thinking but like I
mentioned there are going to be other
variants of the same characters in
Deadpool 3 we will see the old X-Men
return but these aren't going to be the
same X-Men that we see in Avengers
Secret Wars hopefully what happens in
Avengers Secret Wars is that the heroes
from all of these different universes
that are being affected by the king War
are going to have to come together with
Heroes of the other universes and kind
of form a giant Avengers team and when I
say The Avengers I'm including the X-Men
in there I'm including the Fantastic
Four in there any Illuminati members
just like we saw in Avengers Infinity
war and end game the Guardians of the
Galaxy were part of the Avengers Doctor
Strange Spider-Man and so on and so
forth so we're kind of just grouping all
of the heroes here under the Avengers
title because that's essentially what it
will be Avengers Secret Wars and in this
we will see really great versions of
these X-Men characters the true great
versions that we've seen in the original
X-Men films not good X-Men characters
turned evil controlling an entire
universe that Deadpool has to kill that
of course is extremely exciting and very
intriguing and I can't wait to see it
but I also can't wait to see the
original X-Men that we knew grew up with
and loved now as far as the new X-Men
are concerned we've talked about this
many times on the channel Marvel Studios
is probably waiting till phase seven
after Secret forced to start introducing
true new X-Men characters like the new
Cyclops a new Professor X a new
Wolverine new Magneto so on and so forth
but we really haven't heard anything
official from Kevin feige so hopefully
he addresses this at sdcc now another
birthday Scoop from can we get some
toast is that we are going to receive
the first trailer for The Echo series
during San Diego Comic-Con and they say
from everything I've heard it sounds
amazing so that's one big announcement
coming at sdcc and basically from
everything that we've heard about the
echo series we are going to see Echo as
she Rises to the ranks of the tracksuit
Mafia via flashbacks and we are going to
see a current day Kingpin and Daredevil
so a lot to look forward to in that
series and the other big thing that
we're expecting to happen at San Diego
Comic-Con right now is sort of a
rescheduling or restructuring of
Marvel's Phase 5 and phase six plus not
to mention the reveal of Basics you
probably have heard that Marvel Studios
is kind of restarting structuring the
way they go about things and basically
what that means according to Kevin feige
Marvel Studios president and Bob Iger
CEO of Disney currently they're
basically going to produce less content
less Disney Plus shows less movies but
we're unsure of when that is going to
start we're unsure if that'll affect
phase five or if it's just going to
affect phase six and does this affect
kind of the original plan that Marvel
Studios had are any movies or shows
getting cut have they rethought some of
the story planned especially with
everything going on with Jonathan Majors
right now which in turn is another thing
that we're hoping to get some sort of a
clarification on from Marvel Studios and
maybe at San Diego Comic-Con Kevin feige
will come out and simply State hey we're
keeping Jonathan Majors nothing's
happening or hey we are recasting king
or if they truly do decide to do the
extreme which is entirely an option they
could actually Veer away from the King
storyline so he could come out and say
hey we're actually going to bring in a
different villain which would be truly
shocking but we have heard that some
major announcements are going to be
going down at sdcc and of course if we
hear anything else about what they could
be we'll do an update video so be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and be sure to let us know
how excited you are about the original
X-Men returning in the comments down
below we'll link our patreon our website
and our Discord server down below and in
the description and of course you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf
please